[Música]
y
este lunes regresan a la escuela casi
900 mil maestros en francés que deben
dejar todo preparado para la vuelta este
martes de más de 12 millones de alumnos
en un regreso que es obligatorio según
recordó al ministro de educación y en un
contexto de rebrote del cobi 19 por lo
mismo las mascarillas son obligatorias
para todos los adultos de la escuela
profesores o no y para los niños a
partir de los 11 años que deberán
usarlas no solo en la sala de clases
sino que también en la recreación en la
cantina ya está en las clases de música
novelas de deportes donde se deberá
respetar una distancia de al menos dos
metros entre los alumnos a los padres se
les pide esfuerzo primero pagar las
mascarillas pues el estado solo para
costear las de tres millones de familias
más vulnerables pero también se les pide
no enviar a los niños al colegio si
tienen más de 38 grados de temperatura y
en el caso de las escuelas maternales
los más pequeñitos no acompañarlos hasta
la sala de clases como suele ser la
costumbre los profesores se quejan
primero de que el gobierno no ha
invertido lo suficiente para hacer
escuelas que respeten verdaderamente las
medidas sanitarias y en segundo lugar
porque dicen que la mascarilla le quita
humanidad a su trabajo
[Música]
a partir del primero de septiembre
comenzar el año lectivo 2020 2021 de
manera no presencial en ecuador un poco
más de 1.800.000 estudiantes en el
régimen sierra amazonía además en el
país andino se aprobó un plan piloto
para dos colegios privados en la ciudad
de guayaquil con retorno presencial de
estudiantes un plan que generó
controversia porque la alcaldesa de la
ciudad cynthia viteri rechazó la
aprobación y aseguró que no se harán
pruebas con estudiantes dejando claro
que colegio que apertura sus clases
presenciales será clausurado al dilema
de volver o no volver a las aulas de
clases existe el miedo de docentes que
temen contagiarse otras aseguran que
están obligadas a trabajar en colegios
privados y que de no ir deben perder su
trabajo impartir clases en línea
significará un reto un ecuador donde
sólo el 23 por ciento de los hogares
posee un computador de escritorio y el
28 por ciento un computador portátil
mientras que el 45 por ciento de los
hogares tiene acceso a internet según el
instituto nacional de estadística
[Música]
aquí en la provincia de québec los
estudiantes regresan a las escuelas
antes que en el resto de canadá el plan
de reapertura es una buena noticia para
muchos ansiosos por volver a una rutina
más normal durante el verano el gobierno
actualizó el plan de acuerdo con
recomendaciones médicas éstas incluyen
el requisito para los estudiantes
mayores de usar máscaras al interior de
los edificios escolares aunque no en las
aulas pero hay quienes creen que en el
clan no es suficiente para prevenir una
nueva ola de el coronavirus la provincia
tiene alrededor de 1200 casos activos en
este momento más de 150 médicos con
niños condenaron el plan en una carta
abierta y señalan aspectos como la falta
de un mandato de máscaras para los
estudiantes jóvenes y la no reducción en
los tamaños de las clases
el abogado you this way' ha iniciado una
batalla legal contra el gobierno alega
que es inconstitucional que la mayoría
de los estudiantes incluye algunos con
afecciones médicas relevantes
no puedan elegir el aprendizaje a
distancia a un tiempo realmente
[Música]